welcome back to new rockstars doctor
strange has given us a look into the
multiverse of madness and all i can say
is the 616 better be preparing to tackle
their greatest threat ever the pizza
papa because that meant that a lot of a
lot of calories and those pizza bottles
a lot of cholesterol the bill comes due
and the pizza papa always gets paid in
one way or the other this is rogue
theory the show where we pitch the
wildest theories for the nerdy titles
that we love my name is mt and going
world with me today is someone i love in
every universe it's jessica clements
what's going on josh hey piece of bubble
always gets paid pizza papa always gets
paid it's like such a vague threat but
like probably the biggest threat in the
mcu so far um i'm scared of pizza papa
oh my pizza papa breaking my knees and
someone who always knows exactly which
universe we need to jump to it's whitney
van landingham what's going on girl
oh man i am
so
so ready to take you to this
let's go
let's get out of this one this one is
terrible
like the blue ad hasn't started right
you're just making sure
dear lord
and finally a man who knows how to
battle with music notes and host of the
film's philosopher's podcast it's eddie
villanueva what's going on eddie
bloody hell i'm going to wet myself no
not really
that was me for the first 10 years of my
life i was a hardcore bed wet already so
uh
i feel that hardcore
for well maybe not 10. was it 10 i don't
know it was a while my parents were
concerned
as an adult like former bed winner as a
kid like
there's always the fear of like what if
i wake up and
the [ __ ] has started once again oh
yeah the fear is real the fear is real
did your parents do the thing that mine
did where like because i also went my
bed a bunch when i was a kid uh did they
put plastic sheets on your bed
underneath your regular sheets i was
crinkle crackling all the drivers
they were so annoying they were the most
annoying things ever and i didn't even
like realize you were the reason why
people why your parents would have to
leave towels in the car that's that's
yes
hey
[Laughter]
now i think we can all agree that seeing
the 838 universe in the multiverse of
madness movie was one of the most
exciting parts of the doctor strange
sequel but i have so many questions and
i want to know so many more details
about this particular universe with the
illuminati so this leads us to our first
topic of today
who are the 838 avengers because
assuming captain carter is slash was the
leader of the avengers in that universe
before she got a
half off she got sliced and uh oof sorry
uh peggy can't catch a break
who else would be
seriously sorry steve um you think he's
probably not alive to see that um but
who else would be on this lineup like
steve rogers in the hydra stomper maybe
if he's still alive no
god
kick his ass out of here
um
let like lip like let her let uh let uh
carter captain carter just live let her
let her be her without freaking steve
rogers um
i really want to live in that universe
838 but i also want in that universe
because my favorite parts of marvel
movies are when they're like what the
hell are the mo like what the [ __ ] are
the avengers so i don't want there to be
avengers in this universe i don't want
there to be avengers i want there to be
a team i want everybody to work solo but
but to be playing up that rogue theory
since we already got professor x there's
mutants right there's got to be mutants
in this world so i do want there to be
like the gene gray
uh to clearly be one of the members of
the avengers i feel like she would take
the place of what wanda would have been
on the avengers in that world okay but
which one which which jean grey are we
talking about i'm talking about i'm
talking about first movie we see jean
grey i don't want her to be the phoenix
yet okay i don't want her to be uh that
oh good
down sorry my cat in this freaking
window dude this bird she will not stop
and it's
this burden has chose the worst place to
set up because now my cat is trying to
attack them but um yeah i just wanted to
be like the jean grey that we saw in the
like
the second movie uh only because that
jean grey was also like
more coherent
um if that makes sense so that makes
sense she wasn't as like crazy and we're
not getting young jean grey also we're
getting like
middle-aged normal jean grey um
but i want there to be a couple of
mutants on there you could put like
who else would be on there i guess you
could put like
no i don't wanna put wolverine on there
uh you put storm on there oh you'd
absolutely have to put storm on there
storm would have to be like the leader
oh yeah for sure she would totally be on
the adventures i think spider-man would
also but i want spider-man's uncle ben
to be the pizza papa
um i wanted to be bruce campbell and
when he gets home when he gets home
after that three-week fight spider-man's
like what's happened to you after peter
parker's like what's happened to you and
he's just like oh this freaking wizard
of the cave
had me punching myself for three weeks
in the same spot
so when we were talking about topics for
this one this one came up and i'm
thinking like actual like team teams
just because i feel like marvel has
enough teams going on that we could
actually see a plausible one and
honestly the only thing that really came
to mind for me because i really liked
uh the idea that those core team that we
saw on the illuminati
are no longer
you know they're they're not leading the
avengers they're in the illuminati let's
just put it that way and so the the
first thing that came to mind was the
2010 new avengers
uh the one actually led by the
illustrious luke cage
um
which has a really good plethora of
folks i mean you got luke cage um you
got let's see it was luke cage victoria
hands in it which we've seen her in uh
agents of shield uh we got iron fist
jessica jones miss marvel
uh thing
um i mean it's a lot of folks that could
plausibly be in that universe especially
since we do get the incredible uh i
guess spoiler alert the incredible
reveal of ben richards uh uh or read
richard sorry in the uh in this universe
and so if reed richards is there ben
should ben grimm should be there to be
the thing and uh i i feel like we got to
pull in more of the great things from
like the netflix slash disney plus now
series and and i want to see things like
luke cage i want to see jessica jones i
want to see you know daredevil come into
the fray you know i want to see a new
iron fist you know i want to see all
these different opportunities for the
shows that we've already come to know
and love and see them get an opportunity
in this and and i think that would be a
great platform for that like can you
imagine luke cage leading the avengers
what i like about your pitch is you just
chose a bunch of people that are just
very strong so when it's like actually
time to fly they're like i can jump high
yeah
they can run just run to their their
situation
they are never gonna be quiet in any
situation right who wants a piggyback
ride while i jump around the city
captain marvel can fly
oh did you okay i was like
i heard the iron luke cage jessica jones
you said the thing
[Laughter]
i'm sorry miss marvel
i mean i mean you could
yeah you can grow you could carry the
thing i mean you can just you know
he's pretty light
exactly but no i love this idea of like
you know just having this like
avengers team in this 838 universe that
is like a fully realized avengers team
that we would see in like the comics
because like we do have all of these um
actors that have been assigned to these
roles but like there's kind of spread
out throughout the marvel cinematic
multiverse at this point so like if and
we see that the illuminati seems to be a
amalgamation of all the marvel stuff and
the marvel characters that we we've
known across the years so it makes sense
that the avengers team would also be an
amalgamation of like you know uh luke
cage that's played by i forget the
actor's name why am i blanking on his
name he's awesome dude sexy man sexy
ball blackman nope that's you emt sorry
man uh
sorry mt got you and luke cage mixed up
so
[Music]
and the easy
and the watcher
the watcher
jeffrey morgan
jay washington uh we can keep naming off
our famous black friends mike
his name is mike coulter
mike coulter yes oh my god
i i remember him from the tyler perry
movies yeah you do baby and viola davis
are cousins they're cousins if you guys
i think that's that's a sexy family
viola davis and oh they might my coulter
are cousins if i'm not mistaken a sexy
family also a brilliant acting family
that acting tree is in their freaking
jeans if that's true but i mean in all
honesty i just i want to see the
defenders done right like honestly i
want to see
kevin feige get his hand on the
defenders put him into an avengers team
and say all right this is what you were
supposed to get you know kind of thing
because uh you know i don't know i
thought they kind of did them a little
funky i would love that i would really
love to see it but what you got whitney
ah man okay well i'm gonna go ahead and
say that since
this so like eight eight three eight
that universe is kind of like the utopia
right like that's like the one where
like they got rainbow clouds it better
be a youtube yeah renewable energy is
happening the planet isn't on fire or
dying the red light green light game is
flipped you know red light green light
is flipped the game now
um so to me because that universe was
able to get everything else so perfectly
right
um i think that in the 838 universe
morbius is the head of the avengers oh
my god did morbius correctly in 838 and
so he's actually a really cool guy
in that universe he's actually the
coolest guy
he's everyone's favorite marvel hero and
uh
yeah so the the the avengers are led by
morbius co-captain
frog man
oh my god oh my gosh
the wholesome king a wholesome king by
the way this is random someone tweeted
me an image of um tony stark receiving a
letter he's going through a hard time
and who does he get a letter from only
the most wholesome man in the universe
frogman telling him that he can do it
he's like you don't give up tony you can
do it that's why eugene patilio is the
best marvel character ever sorry
continue the end frog writes the end
rock man is a nice man and so she's also
in the avengers um
then i'm going to say we have squirrel
girl because i like her yeah and i think
she's sweet uh she's the best and uh
side note really quick to that have you
guys been checking out the the disney
podcast for squirrel girl
no it is amazing it is hilarious there
is like a
the amazing squirrel girl radio show or
something like that she's doing like a
college radio show
like we're totally doing a plug right
now for marvel but they put it out
there's like three or four episodes out
right now you can get a subscription to
get the next episode ahead but it's so
funny her bio says i kick butts and eat
nuts not always in that one squirrel
girl
but if you check it out it's super fun
and it's definitely a really good listen
to because uh
it's really incorporating a lot more of
like
squirrel girl into the mcu because she
talks about everything that's happening
in the mcu as well in the form of
squirrel girl yeah it's it's funny uh
that one girl that that one actress that
everybody's been really pushing for to
play squirrel girl is the one voicing
her in the podcast oh that's good just
another reason they're like
cast her we're just basically making it
happen that would be the worst thing if
they casted a different person for her
and then they still have that freaking
radio show i'd be so irritated i'd be
like
i'm just gonna raise
freaking hell you can eat a bunch of
nuts
going weight myself but okay morby is a
frog man we got squirrel girl frog man
squirrel girl and my last pick because
this is a different multiverse so
anything is possible anything at all and
so my last pick is gonna be dominic
toretto from the fast and the furious
because in 838 he's an avenger
i
would love that that would be kind of
crazy
i mean i mean after pietro died
he's the next best option yes exactly
they need the new piedro imagine if in
one division instead of um the the fox
x-men pietro we got just vin diesel's
like oh i was the next best option i was
the fastest thing that agatha could find
oh no but you know what the moment would
be in this in the 838 universe you know
uh back in uh what was it ultron when
kobe smulders maria hill is like
explaining them and she's like he's fast
and she's weird but this time it's
he's fast and he's also furious
there you go
there you go that works
i can totally see that happening kobe
would deliver that perfectly and then
you're gonna have this awkward exchange
between you know groot and vin diesel as
dominique toretto yes you're so familiar
but no now that we're like building like
our own little fake avengers like these
are all amazing theories you guys are
all amazing but i really do love this
idea of just to have i'm a huge frogman
lover whitney knows this
i just i love me like i need frogmen on
the avengers at some point at any point
just give them to us seriously he's
literally marvel's kickass if you liked
kick ass with um
aaron taylor johnson
that's basically frogman in my eyes um
so like i'm gonna give whitney at 20 000
rogue points for that one because it's
just it's super rogue it's super crazy i
love it um but you guys also had amazing
theories as always because i love you
guys and you're super smart so i'm going
to give you guys 17 000
points each for your amazing theories
because i really do want to see the
netflix defenders incorporated into this
avengers universe and like i just i need
to see it because like freaking new cage
like
people never really remember that luke
cage sort of led the avengers and he was
like the head honcho like yes who they
looked up to and all that stuff so like
i want that i want to see that it's some
universe at least like a cameo i want to
see them i want to see him in that
leader role because it's really dope
they've all established he's very hot so
they should just make him the leader of
the avengers
like that is an attractive man he's fine
as well
fine as hell
oh
don't even get me started martin luther
king gave a thumbs up um during uh when
uh jess jess and luke cage um got
together monitor king empty when i
wanted no brother the king mt
and luke cage what did the three have in
common
sexy bald
[Laughter]
just a sexy black sexy black man there
you go sexy black men yes sexy black men
i mean changing the world myself in that
category but hey i i feel honored thank
you very much sexy black men who are
changing the world there you go that are
changing the world thank you
there you go they're changing the world
only mta and martin luther king which
you guys kind of almost have the same
initials i don't know how i feel about
that we'll talk about it
how about that later i'm the
reincarnation oh i know
[Laughter]
what if in another universe it works and
another yeah in a different universe you
are martin luther king jr um the poor
black people watching this are like will
you please stop the poor black people
and i'm sorry i'm so excited i'm pretty
sure some of our audience are also
saying in another universe mt is a
variant of seth rogen so just saying
i do have like a seth rogen laughs
sometimes i don't know why i do i don't
know when i started doing it but like
yeah you are great
[Laughter]
i have like a chaotic laugh it's very
that's why i like it
there you go
all right but up next we are going to
talk about doctor strange's career
aspirations beyond being a doctor but
first um there's stuff that i have to
say head on over to new
rockstarsmerch.com to take a look at our
awesome merch options our partners at
epic hero just released their newest
latest obsession shirt inspired by
doctor strange called shattered madness
and like all the latest obsession shirts
it's limited edition so once it's gone
from this universe it's gone for good
like you know all the dark holds
apparently so grabbing some of our merch
is a great way to support the channel so
be sure to check out all of our awesome
merch options over at new
rockstarsmerch.com
spring is here and it's time to get
sprung with blue chew blue chew is a
unique online service that delivers the
same active ingredients as viagra and
cialis but in chewable tablets at the
fraction of the cost you're going to put
them in your mouth you're going to go
big old boner big old boner that's how
that works you can take them anytime day
or night so you can plan ahead or be
ready whenever the opportunity or the
erection arises the process is simple
sign up at bluechew.com consult with one
of their licensed medical providers and
once you're approved you'll receive your
prescription and your rock hard penis in
just a few days it's all done online
there's no visits to the doctor's office
you don't have to go tell some guy in
khaki pants that you can't get laid
because your dick is always flaccid you
don't have to have that uncomfortable
conversation with someone no awkward no
waiting in line at the pharmacy no
getting up to the counter and the hot
pharmacist is like hey big boy what are
you buying today some advil and you're
like no my dick is broken you don't have
to have that conversation with anyone
blue chews tablets are made in the usa
and prepared and shipped direct to your
door in a discreet package everyone in
the multiverse is looking for confidence
they're also looking to just be so
goddamn like a pillar like a roman
coliseum down there that's how hard you
want to be everyone in the multiverse
wants that everybody wants that
confidence and blue chew can give it to
you it really can if you could benefit
from some extra confidence when it's
time to perform luchu can help and we've
got a special deal for our listeners try
bluetooth free when you use our promo
code reload checkout just pay five
dollar shipping that's bluetooth promo
code rogue to receive your first month
free visit bluechew.com for more details
and important safety information and we
thank bluechu for sponsoring the podcast
the code is rogue but your boner will be
tame as hell
did i do enthusiasm during this
bluetooth i've never seen a bluetooth so
enthusiastic it was amazing
i mean she's gonna give tommy a run for
his money i want everyone to get a boner
guys i just want everyone to have one
everyone deserves everyone deserves a
boner
[Music]
when i run for president that will be my
platform it will be a very solid
platform because of the bluetooth a very
strong
firm
firm platform
a turgid detergent platform
a detergent platform if you will back in
my day it would never be caught wearing
sweatpants and joggers outside of your
home or the gym after you took a blue
chew that's a bad idea just kidding ah
let me try this again
we can't merge the brands yes you can
back in my day you would never be caught
wearing sweatpants and joggers outside
of your home or the gym we dressed in
only the finest apparel in public but
now things have changed and the youths
are in charge and the rules are out the
window so our friends at stands are
making a full line of sweatpants joggers
hoodies and more that you'll be proud to
be seen wearing all over town and not
just socks anymore that just sucks socks
worthless
that's where they started stance is
bringing color comfort and creativity
from toe to head with the launch of our
all-new apparel line that's right what
started out as a radical reinvention of
your sock drawer is now expanding to the
entire wardrobe the entire thing
colonization is happening it's spreading
out check out stance's super soft line
of sweatpants and joggers shirts hoodies
hats and more now available in a full
range of fits prints fabrics and fun
embrace a life of superior comfort and
creative expression with everyday active
apparel that truly is stitched different
they have really fun patterns and colors
and even partner with brands like the
simpsons star wars disney major league
baseball and the nba stance's philosophy
is that you should never have to
sacrifice your own individual style for
the sake of comfort and now you don't
have to so whether you're relaxing
around the house working out at the gym
or running all over town stance now
delivers its signature softness and
creativity and a full line of active
apparel styles from toe to head stance
has got you covered so head on over to
stance.com and get 15 off your first
purchase use promo code rogue at
checkout to apply enjoy the color and
comfort of a life less ordinary with
stance stitched different we also want
to thank our partners at athletic greens
because off-screen producer brandon
recently started taking their ag-1 every
day to improve his immune system and
give him more energy one scoop of ag1 in
just a cup of water provides 75 high
quality vitamins minerals whole food
source superfoods probiotics and
adaptogens to help you start your day
right brandon loves it because he can
make it quickly in the morning before
work and it supports mental clarity and
alertness like that dude is sharp all
the time because of athletic greens and
athletic greens uses the best of the
best products based on the latest
science with constant product iterations
and third-party testing and for every
purchase they donate to organizations
helping to get nutritious food to kids
in need including including no kid
hungry here in the u.s it's just one
scoop of ag-1 in a cup of water every
day that's it no need for a million
different pills and supplements to look
out for your health to make it easy
athletic greens is going to give you a
free one year supply of immune
supporting vitamin d and five free
travel packs with your first purchase
vitamin d super important i'm deficient
so this is great so all you have to do
is visit athleticgreens.com rogue again
this is
athleticgreens.com rogue to take
ownership over your health and pick up
the ultimate daily nutritional insurance
all right the end of multiverse of
madness are our good doctor strange
living with his new third eye and
perhaps meeting a new love to battle the
forces of evil with but does stephen
have any other aspirations so this leads
us to our second topic for today will
steven strange ever be the sorcerer
supreme again because the mcu seems to
be embracing a theme for its heroes
passing on the torch so you know with
thor stepping away from asgard to let
valkyrie rule to steve rogers handing
the captain america manchel to sam
wilson do we think strange is done
trying to reclaim the title of sorcerer
supreme even when america chavez implied
that every stephen strange in the
multiverse is a social supreme yeah what
do you guys think i think yeah i i feel
like this is
benedict cumberbatch is a very nuanced
actor and i feel like with benedict
cumberbatch's ability to do so many
other things um i feel like this is one
of those moments where he's now
building the platform to where he passes
the mantle fully uh even to the point
where he replaces even himself with
another doctor strange and and by that i
mean neither uh because we get that
great introduction of clea at the end of
the uh of the film spoiler whatever uh
[Laughter]
and so with clia coming in um there's
options for either making clia the next
sorcerer supreme or just the new
quote-unquote doctor strange or we get
the uh the introduction of stephen
strange and clea's son steven jr which
there is a storyline in the comics uh
where
stephen jr uh is born and he's like a
young teenager and steven strange
actually disappears uh like he's gone
for some reason
i'm so sorry it was my cat oh my god i'm
so sorry keep going i'm going to mute
myself for a second
hey man i i hate when the father's
disappeared too man that's not cool when
yeah and they disappear what they have
my dad also went out for a carton of
cigarettes and never came back so i feel
the reason
i feel he's young stephen
but so he becomes essentially the next
sorcerer supreme essentially he takes
over the mantle for his father becomes a
sorcerer and so forth and so i feel like
this is building that platform so
benedict cumberbatch can continue to do
all the other things because i feel like
benedict cumberbatch isn't the type of
actor who wants to be pigeonholed in one
particular role for too long i mean he
did the same thing with sherlock you
know and and several other things i mean
he's just somebody i feel who has no
problem just saying all right i think
i'm good let's start making the ways to
transition out and do other things so
like so you're saying that like you feel
like benedict cumberbatch is going to
like transition out of the mcu
completely i feel like it yeah i feel
like he's he's gonna i mean he may do
like an appearance later down the road
or something but i feel like he's
starting to pave the way so that he can
pass that torch and have other uh either
notable
strange family uh take over or pass
everything over to wong and have wang be
the main kind of point of contact for
for sorcery in that universe
i really do like this idea of clia being
the social supreme down the line once
you know wong is done with it um because
like you know it's just really cool to
see a female source of supreme in the
mcu um and like you know i and stephen
jr like i had no idea that steven junior
and like that whole arc with him like
taking over the mantle so like i would
love to see that as well and like you
know it doesn't make sense to me and
like you said like benedict cumberbatch
is this actor he likes to do different
types of things but he also like even in
the role of doctor strange i feel like
the source for supreme
like we see in the movie like it's sort
of like a very you have a lot of
responsibility like you have to take
care of all these wizards and like you
have the fate of the world in your hands
and i feel like doctor strange as a
character is a more adventurous he's
like i just wanna
do it out like mess around with magic
and like you know like meet an
attractive woman and go to another
dimension with her and all that stuff um
so like you know i feel like he can't
really do that as the president of magic
so he's like ah president of magic
sir president of magic he was knighted
as the king of magic
he's
so funny him and david blaine are in the
illuminati together along with and and
chris chris angel's working
david blaine and chris angel are the
three president vice president and the
secretary of magic
sometimes we invite that one kid from
yu-gi-oh but that's it
do you think that chris angel could take
out wanda and why is the answer
yes absolutely 100
can wanda come down from wires
i'm sorry does wanda have a residency in
las vegas i didn't think so we get this
appearance of all these all these
sorcerers and magicians and then in
comes this wheelchair and it's david
copperfield
wanda plays at the lux store right
before a carrot top
right before carrot top whoever wants to
go see what they
want to open for carrot top feel free i
also just really i like the idea of like
instead of an old captain america it's
just really old lance burton and he's
like world decrepit
there you go now we've built the
avengers of magicians you guys honestly
that should have been the topic today
entirely of magicians can i take back my
previous answer
this should have been the question
this is the real question they're gonna
be known as the las vegas avengers the
laws of the las vegas avengers you know
that carrot top is the head of the las
vegas avengers the buff older carrot top
two no thanks yo if party thor is not on
this team we've done something
about vegas oh party though yes party
floors on the vegas avengers and they
keep calling celine dion and she keeps
refusing to join
she will not join and she will not
thor's like bring the wizards
absolutely
oh god okay so going back to the
the lesser of the two topics
i'm joking brandon this is a great
question
clearly i just love vegas and i love
vegas magicians and i love a vegas
magician baby who are the two who are
the two the two magicians in vegas the
pen and teller
oh
oh my god yeah that would be
and teller is black [ __ ]
because he doesn't talk
because he doesn't yeah yes yes
that is so funny
that's amazing that's perfect that's a
thousand percent perfect this up for me
right now it'll be my new background on
my on my on my twitter i will put it i
will change anybody out there who can do
fan art of the las vegas avengers for us
please yeah we've already we made it
easy for you yeah i will retweet it i
will i will shout it out i'll make it
every banner of everything
tyler new rockstars to retweet it
oh yeah we will force tyler to retweet
it if somebody makes us the las vegas
avengers okay sorry sorry sorry will
steven strange ever be yeah and wait
sorry no it's totally fine we're going
rogue and we did go rogue baby that
wasn't even a rogue theory though that
was just going on that wasn't even the
wrong question it just happened that way
um i think i don't think he's ever gonna
be the source of supreme again and i
think mainly why he shouldn't be the
source of premium is because he did have
a chance to take a look at the darkhold
and i'm not trying to say people that
take the darkhold are mistrustworthy but
i
uh seen his believing uh once you read
that it takes over you and it takes over
everything else so i don't think he's
like gonna be completely bad but i do
think just because he inherited a little
bit from the dark hole it might be best
to just keep roaming the galaxy with
freaking um or the multiverse uh with uh
clea instead of becoming the source of
supreme in charge of the
everything i think that's great as wong
it should stay warm it should have
always been wrong too because wong is
the only person that is like
horse blinders keeping it straight
recognizing what's really wrong and no
one listens to them so i think keeping
strange going crazy in other galaxies
having fun and have a new girl go ahead
long being the like actual teacher is
probably the best idea
there you go that wasn't wrong but it
was really good no like i think that
that's a really you raise a really good
point with uh the fact that he has
dipped in the dark hole because like one
of my favorite moments from multiverse
of madness is when wanda sees strange
dreamwalking and he's like you're a
hypocrite because like that sort of
calls back to when casilius called the
ancient one hypocrite for using the
powers of the dark dimension to extend
her life so i think that you know this
idea of like not having a
social supreme that is dark influenced
it means a lot for the people of comtaj
and like for wong because like they
don't like they sort of agree with mordo
in the way it's like we have to be
responsible we can't be super crazy with
our power and doctor strange he's the
most irresponsible man that we know and
so
maybe not let him be the source of
supreme until he can learn how to well
and i think i think
part of that as well is like i feel like
once you use the dark it's like that
threshold once you cross that threshold
you can't really go back
and it just like once you go black you
can't go back it's a basic lobby
it's the basic law of the universe yes
everyone knows this once you go black
you can't go back all right that's
that's just how it is jessica jones blue
cane she was like i'm going right there
like rosario dawson had no chance just
saying once you go rosario dawson you
never go back oh my god i would kill
everybody for rosario dawson that's
that's that goes without saying that
first episode of that other season with
luke cage when he gets out of prison
like that was like straight up they were
in every part of that room him and
rosario dawson it was like oh my god
this is marvel
marvel yeah that was uh pretty hard
don't get me started oh god he's so fine
girl that man drives me crazy so does
rosario dawson i don't need this i don't
need this right now
we're on rope
theory um but no um but you got whitney
uh well yeah so i kind of i'm i'm torn
with this one because on one hand i'm
like okay but the character of dr
strange is relentlessly annoying in his
pursuit to become sorcerer's supreme
like up until now he's been so obnoxious
about wanting the title so bad so
there's like a part of me that's like
okay but like
people don't change that much he's still
gonna want it you know like that's still
gonna be something that maybe he wants
down the line but i do agree that like
right now
he saw what happened with the darkhold
he read the darkhold so he's like
enlightened now he's educated now he
understands and like you know just said
once you
put the dark hold it sticks with you
forever
and if you um
i was like reading through because i was
just like looking at my dark cold
history for like a video i was writing
the other day and i was reading about
all of the other people who have like
temporarily mastered the darkhold and
how all of them met like horrible fates
like nobody who's read the darkhold has
just like been okay afterwards ever like
not even one person every single person
has either had their soul like enslaved
and damned or they've died in a horrific
way or like they've been possessed by
catholic the
so i do think that because of that
yeah it's kind of hard to get elected
president of magic when you have like
when part of your soul already belongs
to a demon so yeah so like i i think
that he'll still want to be sorcerer
supreme in his heart i don't know if he
should be though like i don't know i
don't think that they should let him be
[Laughter]
honestly like i i do like that idea
because like we know like stephen
strange is the biggest ego
ever like one of the biggest heroes in
marvel universe especially after a tony
stark passed away he he definitely wants
the title of sorcerer's supreme but i
think by the end of this trilogy what
we're going to see is him rejecting the
whole
idea of social supreme because like it's
his character development he's like you
know what i don't need to have the title
to make a difference and to be you know
good it's not about me it's about
everyone which is what the whole
message of doctor strange one was i just
think i think he respects wong too much
i think he is arrogant but i think
before his arrogance is his closeness to
wong and seeing all the stuff wong's
done for him and for the um
for
the sanctum in general but i think he
saw so much of that that he's like i
don't need to take this title to be
recognized as like the most powerful
because this does belong to wong i think
once if wang did die
cat
if long did die then
she started scaling
yeah once one dies cat um he will come
back she starts scaling the screen and i
live on the third floor so she will fall
out i have to scream her name
she's named after cat dennings also i'm
not a monster once wong dies your cat is
gonna become sorcerer's surprise god
forbid
god forbid she will kill every bird in
the universe she will come for every
living thing with wings
yeah without the dark hole god forbid we
will never no dark holes
no door mamamoo bargaining just all
birds dead bad eagles are already going
extinct my cat will make sure that deed
good's done like i can't live
we can't we can't
um but yeah once wong passes or just
like gives away the mantle or does
whatever that's when strange will want
to take it back
but i think until then as long as wong
is alive i i think he's respected yeah
cause that's like his bestie yeah and
they rag on each other but they love
each other i love their relationship so
much like you too their relationship is
really like they've grown so much
together that she's like all right i
used to like think you're an annoying
librarian and now you're like my brother
so this is really cool that bow that he
finally gave him at the end of the movie
was like another bow of like yeah
another relationship of theirs have now
crossed another tier like they are now
um
having sex maybe who knows
[Laughter]
but no
these are all very valid points and like
these and like i really do think that
you know stephen strange will likely not
be the sorcerer supreme again um which
is kind of weird because like he has
traditionally been the social supreme in
the comics but it seems like that this
there is a whole arc of like
him like sort of rejecting himself and
like sort of just letting himself go and
putting his ego aside and like you know
having putting his trust in other people
like with wong and like with christine
at the end of multiverse of madness with
spider-man in the entirety of spider-man
no way home it's letting himself not be
in the driver's seat which is like what
the whole lesson a multiverse of madness
was but yeah i'm gonna give everyone 100
000 rogue points for this one because
you guys had all super valid points so
which leads us to a rogue
question time where
the true winner will be found because
this is where i'm gonna award uh two
million points this is for two million
points guys so you guys better be
freaking rogue as heck there's two it's
whose line is it anyway rules all right
so it's no the points don't matter all
right here we go
we saw some multiverses in multiverse
and madness i don't know if you noticed
we saw a couple of multiverses but we
could have used more i'm not gonna lie
we could have used a little bit more i
could well i wanted to see um you know
it was a cool universe full of um just
uh haley steinfeld it would have been
great if she was just every avenger
that'd be nice great avengers just
haley's time
hey bishop is iron man i want to see
[ __ ] with a goatee
i want that to happen uh but anyway i
want each of you to pitch me a rogue
universe what you would have liked to
have seen in the film and what makes
that universe so special so let's travel
the multiverse together shall we hug
planet
obviously beaver's just made out of pugs
can you imagine that would be
pug amazing supreme and his little pug
sorcerer supreme suit would be oh i need
to see pizza pug right now pizza papa
pug pizza papa pug always gets a page
i want to see pug marika chavez
jumping through the mud
hunter strange
i want but
a planet that uh everyone is it's the
sims
um everybody's a sims character
everybody's the same
everything's the sims everything must be
played as this is so easily murder me by
just taking the ladder out of the
swimming pool jess and i would just be
in there like that
and we don't know that i would say like
the illuminati but i want to say like
whoever the most powerful villain is it
could be wanda is the one that could
actually control us so like she could
just block us in our basement and set
the house on fire or like
just like order us to do weird things
but um until that day i think
we should all be soon that would be
hilarious i want to speak the same
language it'd be amazing
[Music]
yeah i have two answers okay so uh my
first my first answer is a little bit
more of like what i really really really
wanted to see and it's been something
i've been wanting to see in the mcu
for some time but i know it's going to
take a little bit i want to see
uh 1 million bc avengers universe which
is uh the time frame
where
you actually so the going back to like
when we were talking about the avengers
it was a time where you had
thor
uh i'm sorry uh odin
as
wielding milner you have the actual
sorcerer supreme agamotto
you have firebrand
you have a
demon-possessed uh ghost writer
and there's one other person i think is
it the phoenix i believe so oh uh the uh
original black panther and the phoenix
you're right but i feel like seeing like
agamoto actual agamotto the sorcerer
would be super cool bringing back like
anthony hopkins and d.h so we can fight
that would be fun too i mean i'm pretty
sure anthony now can probably do it on
his own either way
but i feel like that would be a really
great uh universe to go to but the other
universe that i was thinking the other
one that i really really want to see
is oh by the way i feel like that's kind
of where the dinosaurs were at when they
tumbled through those universes
i feel like that may be that time frame
uh but we don't see a lot of it because
we just see you know dinosaurs fighting
um
but i do want to see
the universe uh the duck verse
uh where where everybody
there's there's a duck verse where
there's literally a duck version of
doctor strange
i feel like that would be so great just
to bring in the hilarity of like howard
the duck with duck vendors and and dr
strange and all of that
like i just feel like that would be
something then who who would win the
incursion the pug planet or the duck
planet because they just do what the
spaniards do when they have sex and make
an amalgamation you know just
i don't want to do that i don't want
that
i don't want that that's disgusting
that's filthy
first off they can't breathe
yeah i was like they couldn't breathe
first off they couldn't breathe there's
literally a commercial going on in the
duck in the pug universe if your
lipstick uh doesn't come up blue
if your red lipstick isn't as hard as a
red rocket as you want it to be ew i'm
good i'm solid no thanks
about dog wieners yeah too bad they
exist
dog wieners they're out there in the
multiverse whether you like it or not
dude ducks have weirder wieners than
dogs ducks have coins exactly so why are
we trying to splice them with a [ __ ]
dog no you're right that's a terrible
ducks are kind of [ __ ] up as creatures
if you really look into it ducks are
really bad characters they're really bad
animals not as bad as this animal not as
bad as this bird eating animal
these are all great multiverses i would
have loved to see each and every one of
them especially the pug
duck planet because that i would just i
just want to see what that site is
i want to know what happens
but i i have to give it to you this
eddie's idea of just seeing the old
school avengers because i loved that run
that little small run that they had with
the uh um
yeah they're like million bc avengers
avengers before christ
before christ's christ
wait a minute wait a minute i'm about to
buy this i'm gonna buy this right now
this in the las vegas avengers
oh
yeah i love it i'm here for the las
vegas team up with the before christ
eventually there you go but the las
vegas avengers they don't have they
don't have bc they have bca before chris
angel before
magic until chris angel hit the hit the
seat in 1983. if he was never born in
1983 we don't know what magic is and
then they all have dinner together and
there's a painting of the last magical
supper yes the last magic suffer
with chris angel in the middle
but yes i do love eddie's the idea and
rogue um answer the best for today which
makes eddie today's winner with two
million bajillion points i forget how
much i said
thank you for your answers but of course
all of you guys did amazing as always
and you know the points don't really
matter and we're just like talk about
nerd stuff because rogue theory is fun
that way but that is it for this episode
of rogue theory thank you to our amazing
guests jessica clemons whitney van
laningham and betty betty
uh is venom and eddie brock's ship name
yes bethesda's ship name betty
eddie better from pearl jam oh true
already better from pearl jam sure
okay and eddie villanueva support all of
them on their twitters and everything
that they do and of course you can
support our channels by checking out all
of our of awesome merch over at
newrockstarsmerch.com
and if you have a rogue theory of your
own please share them on our discord if
you are 18 years old and order just the
older whoops
please please
if you're 18 year old please please
shower regularly begging you please we
are really our begging you uh so yeah if
you're 18 years old or older hit that
link in the description box below to
join the conversation and you can you
can follow me at master damage if you
want to see me tweet some really weird
[ __ ] but more importantly you can follow
new rockstars on all our social
platforms we love you guys so much thank
you for spending time with us you guys
are amazing and we'll see you guys next
time goodbye
[Music]
you